we got it
we got it
we want to protect the people of this
city
and apprehend those
who believe they can bring terror to
everyday
fox news alert the maniac who shot up a
new york city subway train arrested
after a 30-hour manhunt brand new video
showing 62-year-old frank james leaving
the police precinct there cops taking
him into custody after someone spotted
him at a mcdonald's
he now faces a terrorism charge after
going on a rampage shooting 10 people
setting off a smoke bomb and injuring 19
others he also had fireworks and was
carrying an axe
police say he had been riding the
subways just hours after carrying out
the attack and officials facing
criticism because cameras inside the
station weren't working
dana
pressing mayor adams on that earlier
how is it possible that the transit
authority had all this money and the
cameras in the station weren't working
and that is what we are communicating
with transit officials now we want to
know if there was any particular reason
if it was a veda problem
we're also learning more about the
suspect authorities revealing he has a
long rap sheet that includes 12 prior
arrests in new york and in new jersey
thankfully the deranged gunman was
spotted by a citizen
look how many people have in new york
nobody catch him like i was working
inside that store and i catch him that's
got something from the god yeah that's
good something from the god and we catch
him always behind this people in america
we don't want any problem here in
america because his life is good
and he gets a reward doesn't he do it 50
i think that i think that his reward
seems to me like the pride yeah and he
loves the city and he wants to be a part
of it uh mayor adams came on america's
newsroom today we were glad to have him
his first interview on fox news channel
and
look i think a lot of people in the city
are pulling for him this is obviously a
good result to get to this point but you
know he also on another network talked
about
what can be done to try to prevent these
things from happening i mean he had a
lot of this uh
had this perpetrator had a lot of social
media posts in his past right and
there's all of these little clues and
that we only seem to get to the clues
after the fact and the other thing is
that the the crime in the city that the
frame decaying piece of the city this
really shattered that
so many families live here and you
cannot afford to take an uber everywhere
the subways are so important to the
lifeblood of the city so um it's good
that they caught him i think that there
was obviously great coordination amongst
the law enforcement but certainly in
citizens like that gentleman greg
godfeld your thoughts on the arrest um
oh it's amazing i mean where would it
where would a city be without sound
police work
we're saying this after a couple of
years now where the police you know
force was pulled back there were fewer
police officers in the subway there were
even fewer police officers on the street
we were all like supposed to be you know
they were more dangerous than the
criminals but there will there will
always end up being the people that
clean up the messes created by the
malignant neglect of our you know
criminal justice system and the mentally
ill they're allowed to be on the streets
it's not social workers it's not
outreach coordinators it's not social
justice activists that catch these guys
it's the police the people that we've
been demonizing for the past two years
you said something about the clues he
was on a fbi watch list right he was a
newsweek reported that yeah he had
twelve private but the reason why the
clues didn't fit a narrative you know he
wasn't part of a white supremacy
movement maybe he was maybe he's a
closet white supremacist i don't know
but you know the fbi had him on a watch
list and boy did they watch him you know
because they were too busy focusing on
parents and school board meetings you
know people on january 6 you know the
preparing a kidnapping of a governor uh
so this is just another example of kind
of an uncomfortable narrative that as
you said yesterday may in fact be going
away quicker than we think because
it didn't fit what the media wants
janine pirro uh they got him so that's
good news but
shouldn't happen in the first place
well first of all they got them
we knew that they would get him the new
york city police department as far as
i'm concerned i've had 30 years
experience uh they're the finest police
department in the world there is no
question
uh it was the crime stoppers uh which is
a very important program for any
prosecutor's office and any police
department people will jump hurdles to
get money to report a crime and it works
uh and it worked in this case i think
the sad part of all this when you see
when you see the politicians like the
governor yesterday running up and saying
this has to stop and even with the mayor
today you know now we're going to make
sure we catch this guy who attempted to
murder new york citizens so i called the
brain room and i said how many citizens
have actually been killed since mayor
adams was became mayor and they said
103. now all of a sudden you know we're
definitely going to stop these people no
we're not mayor adams went to albany he
came back and talked about racism when
he should have talked about bail reform
he should have talked about getting rid
of uh
they've got uh they got rid of qualified
immunity for police we should put a
billion dollars back into the police
force aoc had everybody convinced that
we don't need cops on the metro line we
don't need cops in the subway uh look
there is no surprise here other than the
fact that it's good old-fashioned law
enforcement that works and that keeps us
safe and that will make this city
prosper again but right now this man has
single-handedly scared everyone who
thought about going back on the subway
and public transportation and people
with kids and my own daughter who lives
in brooklyn is now like that's it i'm
done
you know and it's a shame all they have
to do to make this city the citadel on
the hill that it once was was to restore
a law order geraldo rivera we're just
thinking of restoration defund the
police peaked in 2020 now is refund the
police i guarantee you this will be the
impetus the catalyst for a new
pro-police vibe in this town sorely
lacking i have two kids in brooklyn also
they they take the end they take the r
uh you know
this is by far the worst atrocity on the
subway ever so we can't
use this as the example of how awful the
subways are when i was growing up you
know with the graffiti and the thugs and
all the rest of it was a far more uh
harrowing experience going down
into the into the subways but everybody
needs to feel good about it it's the
artery that connects the five boroughs
so
what is it 350 square miles something
like that uh it's so spread out without
the subways the city will not be one
unit it'll be scattered communities
everywhere so it is vital that the mayor
do it i think he's on the right track
you know it's ironic i've been in the
business a long time we got him i i knew
that i knew i had heard that before we
got him it was paul bremmer ambassador
2003 iraq when they got saddam hussein i
celebrated that i celebrate that uh this
uh this uh
frank uh what's his name getting caught
frank james uh he's a loser the mental
illness component is uh is undeniable i
think a bigger uh you know uh clue to
what we need to do is monitoring youtube
and social media because this guy was
all over it i mean what do you want to
say next thursday going to blow up
and i also really want to commend you i
thought it took guts for you on your
evening show yesterday
it is dangerous not to report the race
of a fugitive perp
dangerous felon on the lamb and you say
he's five foot five and heavy set
that could be like everybody else let's
and let's point out he's not five foot
five that was low profiling
wasn't racial profiling level you see
him he's about he's got to be close to
six feet tall yeah he's big well over
200 pounds but you know rather
to bring up the the race aspect of this
this is a hate crime right i mean he
targeted a neighborhood of minorities
and if you look at his social media
profile he had a lot of hate yeah but
the thing is that that will be an angle
that will not be approached right
because it doesn't fit that narrative
greg unless you tell me that he only
shot people of asian descent or who were
whites or this or that and then
identified circumstantially by words
that it was a crime of hate if you if
you do it indiscriminately which
apparently he did then how was it a hate
crime well i think that's an assumption
we don't know how he chose those subway
lines why he uh he hooked into brooklyn
we don't that is all to come that's
still still to come what is obvious is
that this should be a federal offense as
it is i'm delighted that they took it
out of the hands of the local d.a god
bless when i started in the da's office
here in town i believe the feds could do
a much better job they can get them for
life forever
put them in you know six stories
underground let me tell you the reason
the feds have it the feds have it
because under new york say first of all
i think the da's whether in brooklyn or
manhattan
don't have the power that some of the
federal prosecutors do in terms of their
determination but our discovery in new
york state is such that we couldn't
possibly get all the victims and
witnesses and cops and give them the
discovery that they'd have to have in 15
days and they're only defensive no
question there's no question the feds do
have jurisdiction
the light of day after this year remind
yourself about these surveillance
cameras none of them working when you
had a mayor put up a billboard mocking
florida you know over over a parental
rights bill it's like we i mean adults
have to be in charge of cities to get
the priorities right liberals do not
have the priorities correct and the cops
bail them out every single time every
time they catch it i don't mean to talk
so much but
there's a surveillance camera on every
corner every bodega every shop every
supermarket there is surveillance if you
commit a crime outside
forget the stories of the surveillance
cameras not working you will be caught
right i'll tell you one thing the speed
cameras are never broken i mean i just
got two red light cameras the other day
how come those are worse
you remember epstein those cameras
weren't working
i'm tired of hearing about it fire these
people all right we're gonna get to the
bottom of the cameras coming up next
president biden getting a special
delivery from texas
after letting the border crisis run wild
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else